(audience cheers and applauds)
- Welcome back, everybody!
Our next guest is a social
media star, bringing awareness
to a subject most people
find extremely challenging.
She is a hospice nurse who
not only brings comfort
to her patients in their
final chapter of life,
she's bringing hope and
understanding to her
2 million plus followers on TikTok.
Check out what I mean.
- I had this younger
patient, like late forties,
who was passing of cancer
and she was never married.
I showed up for a visit one day
and she's like, "I think I'm going crazy."
And of course I'm like,
"Why do you think that?"
And she says, "This guy I went to college
with is standing at the end of my bed."
And I said, "Did he pass?"
She goes, "I don't think so.
Last I saw him was our college graduation.
I took a job across the
country and we broke up."
So I'm intrigued. And I
said, "Can we Google him?"
So we did. And I found his obituary.
I'm reading it and I said,
"Doesn't look like he was married."
And I got a smile out of her.
So I firmly believe they're together now.
(audience exclaims)
- Oh, she just put out
her first book, y'all.
It's a New York Times bestseller
called "The In-Between"
Unforgettable Encounters
During Life's Final Moments.
Everybody, please give a warm welcome
to nurse Hadley Vlahos.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Oh my God. She walked out and I was like,
"I own this dress."
That was amazing. I love this dress.
It looks so great on you.
Thank you for being here.
- Thank you.
- Thank you for having
me. Yes, this is crazy!
- Abso-
Oh my God, I love your accent so much.
Okay, so wait, do you
experience like that video,
do you experience like
sightings like that?
Do people experience that often?
- Yeah, it's common.
And when I first got into hospice
and I started seeing it, I was like,
"Okay, is this a religious
thing? Is this certain people?"
And I was really surprised
to start talking to my other
coworkers who have been doing it forever.
And they're like, "No, it
doesn't matter their background.
It doesn't matter how they were raised."
This happens to so many different people
and it's very peaceful,
which is what I love.
Like people are coming to
get them from the other side
and it brings them a lot
of peace. It's beautiful.
- Yeah. At such a not, so great time.
You know what I'm saying?
- Yes.
- It's a very hard situation.
So to find beauty in that is wonderful.
It's important for you, right?
To share this experience
with everybody, right?
- It is, I didn't expect it
to be so healing in a way.
It's hard whenever you have
patients who pass with regrets.
And so whenever I share
and people say, "Oh,
I'm learning from this,"
or "I am gaining something from this,"
it makes me feel like my
patients are living on in a way.
- Yeah. And still teaching everybody.
What a beautiful thing.
Like lessons you're learning as well.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- [Kelly] Like while sitting there
and all their advice.
- Yeah.
- What's like one thing that
you love that they've told you,
that you've really taken
to heart? Do you remember?
- Yeah. There is one patient
who, called Elizabeth,
and she was much younger
whenever to be on hospice.
She was in her forties.
- Yeah.
- And I had an eating disorder at the time
that no one knew about.
And she had a disease,
she had lung cancer,
never smoked, picture of health.
Don't know why she had it,
we still don't know why she had it.
She had such a positive outlook.
And I remember sitting
there one day just charting
and she said, "Can I give you some advice?
'Cause I see a lot of myself in you."
And I said, "Yeah, of
course." Put my computer away.
And she said, "I think I spent too much
of my life on the treadmill."
Said, "I really wish I would've
spent more time at the beach
without worrying what
my stomach looked like
and more time with my friends at dinners.
And I really wish I would've
just eaten the cake."
And she hasn't-
- Metaphorically and physically.
- Yeah, exactly.
And she had no idea how
much that meant to me.
I actually left and went and ate some cake
that night at a Christmas party.
- Yeah. Like she told me to eat the cake.
(audience applauds)
- Yeah, yeah,
- Yeah.
So the book is now becoming
a TV series, which is huge!
Congratulations on that.
- Thank you. Thank you.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Yeah, I'm excited for it.
I'm excited for it to reach
more people in different ways.
- Yeah. And to kind of
talk about something
that people don't really
like to talk about.
You know what I'm saying?
Because it can be sad for a lot of people.
And even like talking with my children
about death and grief and
all that kind of stuff
'cause they're young and they're learning
about stuff like that.
I like to try and talk about
it in a more positive manner
of like, "Well, let's worry
about living and not dying."
Like let's worry about this part.
- Yeah.
- And I don't know, I like that it'll kind
of be in our brains a little bit more too.
And that direct impact
of the whole situation
and not being so scary for everybody.
- I think that's so important.
Whenever you talk about
it, takes the fear away.
- Yeah.
- And I think that's really
important for a lot of people.
- Everything I wanted
to say was everything
you just said when you
take the fear out of it.
The weight of it. That was you.
Yeah, well said.
She writes books. (laughter)
Hadley's pretty good at it.
Hadley's book is called "The In-Between"
Unforgettable Encounters
During Life's Final Moments.
And everyone in the audience
is going home with a copy!
(audience cheers)
Hadley's dedicated her life to looking
after people during the
final days of their lives.
For her, it's a passion and a career,
but there are upward of 65 million people
across the country caring
for their own loved ones
who are elderly, disabled,
or chronically ill.
They don't get paid.
They have to give up all their free time.
They make huge sacrifices, our next,
and it's life altering.
And our next guest knows
that experience well.
And now she's stepping
up for fellow caregivers
by giving them love and
much deserved pampering.
So that makes her truly a Rad Human.
(upbeat music)
(audience applauds)
From Caregiver Safe Place,
let's welcome Carletta everybody.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Thank you.
- So y'all have met?
Have y'all met before Hadley?
- Yes, just now.
- Oh, before, backstage.
Okay. They go way back! (laughter)
So what is your experience as caregiver?
- My experience as a caregiver is,
is just like anyone else's.
We just get thrown into this...
situation,
- Situation?
- where you're a caregiver
and you don't know what
you're gonna have to do.
It's not like a job where they teach you
or treat you as though you're gonna know
what your job description is.
Your job description is basically
to love on your loved ones.
- Yeah.
- And my mom,
she was my everything.
So I had to take on that
responsibility of loving her
until her last days.
- Yeah. Woo!
So Hadley, what was it
like to see, I mean,
I'm sure you've seen caregivers
just burn out, right?
That has to be hard.
- It's extremely hard.
- I mean, physically, emotionally,
mentally, all the way.
- It is and y'all are the unsung heroes.
People don't even realize
what people are going through
every day trying to care
for their loved one.
It's extremely difficult.
- [Carletta] Thank you.
- Yeah. Especially if
they can't afford care
and it's just like one of
those things where it's like,
"I don't know what I'm doing."
- Yeah.
- Like I'm not qualified,
but you're thrown into this situation.
- You, you learn.
You figure it out really fast.
- Yeah. Well, Carletta, you
created help for caregivers.
So how did this come about?
- I was in my bed after
taking care of my mom
and with caregiving,
it plays a mental role
where you think that you're going crazy.
You don't realize that you're just,
you're grieving from the moment you start
taking care of them to the end.
So I sat in my bed and I said,
"If I'm feeling this way,
I know it's so many
other caregivers around
that's feeling the same
anxiety that I feel."
- Yeah.
- And sometimes I thought
I was crazy because I would
be mad at her thinking
that she was doing it on purpose
and then I would be happy
because she would be happy.
But then, the moment hits that
you need to get it together.
You have to stay strong for that person.
So with me, I started the foundation
because I said if I was going
through this, I know it had
to be someone else that
was going through this
that was not able to get
the help that they needed.
So I started the foundation
so that I could help
as many caregivers as I
can around the world so
that no one will feel the same stress
and anxiety that I felt as a caregiver.
- Yeah. And just to talk to
someone that's going through it.
You know what I'm saying?
All those feelings are valid.
- Yeah.
- How many people have you
been able to help so far?
- So far it's been 35 to 40 people.
- Wow.
- In which I,
November I gave out about
$1,700 gift cards.
Just everybody that was
submitted to the website.
- Yeah.
- I actually mailed those out
as a surprise for
November Caregiver Month.
And so normally all the
other ones, I will randomly,
if I see you at the airport
and I see you have a loved one
and I feel like you're a family caregiver,
I'll give you a hundred dollar gift card
or a hundred dollars or
whichever one actually works.
Others, I actually fly
across wherever, to Chicago.
I've gone to Chicago to Tampa, to
several different places so far, Orlando.
- Yeah.
- And I've given-
- How do you do that?
How do you keep that up financially?
- I do it all out of my
pocket as of right now.
- What?
- Yeah.
I'm a hairstylist. So what I do is I had
to stay at work from morning to night
because I needed to make enough
money so I can fly to Tampa
and stay there for a
week to surprise this man
that was taking care of his wife.
- Yeah.
- And so I did that
and we raised $200 and something
thousand dollars for him.
- Wow!
(audience applauds)
What? That's amazing!
You are incredible!
Well we love what you are
doing and we are not alone.
Comfort Keepers, a leading
in-home care provider for adults
and seniors is dedicated to
uplifting the human spirit
by delivering customized
services to meet the unique needs
of your loved ones.
To help you give more
caregivers a day off,
they're donating $10,000
just to help you out.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Oh my!
- Thank you so much!
- Hold on.
You have such a great heart.
And you're doing amazing things.
And also this just brings
awareness to people
like you never know what people
are going through at home,
like what they're having to
conquer as well as their job.
- Yes...
I won't let y'all down.
I'll promise I'm gonna
do everything I can do
to make every family caregiver that I know
and that come across me, that I can help
smile at least one day.
- [Kelly] Yeah and not feel so alone.
(audience cheers and applauds)
We will be right back, everybody.